so here we are in sunny Brighton and  this is the Labour battle bus as you can  see which is just driven up from London  first thing this morn is what they were  used to go around the country and here  we are inside the bus at the moment  everyone's got off as we're just waiting  to get going for days you can see you've  got some nice leather seating very  comfortable with tables for journalists  and media and what have you and this is  the spectators perch here I've been  listening to Edna laval on radio for  this morning and at the back here we've  got a little kitchen with everything you  need you've got some coffee and labour  marks no controlling immigration marks  but there is a better future for better  better better plan for a better future I  should say coffee's very delicious  indeed fridges full of water and granola  we've got fruit crisps and plenty of  wine at the back there for later on so  as you can see this is the empty they  were battle Busby going up and down